You saw that we denoted this corrected standard deviation by lower case s. When
we have a sample, this is what we use to approximate the true population
standard deviation sigma. We call this the sample standard deviation. But don't
get confused with the actual standard deviation of a small data set. For
example, let's say we have this data set where n equals 5. To find the standard
deviation of this, we would find the mean, which is 3, take each squared
deviation from the mean. Add up the square deviations, which if also called the
sum of squares, and divide by 5 or n. That's the standard deviation of these
five values. But if we're using this to approximate a larger population that
this sample came from, then we would divide by n minus 1. So, then this would
be 4 in the denominator if we're trying to estimate the standard deviation of
the population. So, don't get confused between these two. But it is kind of
confusing because this, when we use this formula with n minus 1 in the
denominator, it's called the sample standard deviation and it's denoted by
lower case s. So, just remember if you're given a sample and you need to
estimate the population standard deviation, you use this formula with n minus 1
in the denominator. Making the whole standard deviation slightly bigger. That's
a better estimate then of the true population standard deviation sigma. But if
you have a data set and you need to find the standard deviation of that data
set, not approximate a population standard deviation, then you divide by n.